this is jocko podcast number 301 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
how did i end up here
i'm
smart i'm funny i look pretty damn
handsome if i do say so myself
but here i am
nowhere
and it seems this is where i will always
be
nowhere
bedroom
it is not an apartment but it looks like
one
cheap furniture well used carpet
not clean but not dirty
the bedroom is not unique in its wares
bed desk chair dresser
small bedside table with lamp
overhead light
janky ceiling fan spinning at a low
speed
then there is the decor
pictures hung neatly on the walls
they are strange
or at least indicate a strangeness that
is hard to interpret
harmless
but different
johnny walks in
20-something
leaning towards 20.
pretty damn handsome for an unkempt
young man who stays up too late and eats
the wrong foods and drinks more beer and
whiskey than he should
he looks at his brother
johnny is frustrated
he tries to remain restrained but it can
be hard after all these years
what the hell cleaner man i told you
about these shirts
[Music]
artie looks distraught
johnny sees
johnny cannot stay frustrated
after all
this is already his brother
and no one could really be mad at artie
what
is it not clean arty replies earnestly
concerned wondering if he had somehow
failed his brother
no already it isn't that it is not clean
it's clean but it's just a t-shirt
i know
already cuts in
it's a 100 cotton t-shirt i used a warm
warm cycle it shouldn't have shrunk at
all i'm always careful about that
it's not shrunk arty that's not it it's
just
never mind
forget it
forget what johnny what's wrong
this was killing artie
the one thing he was supposed to be good
at and it seemed like he messed it up
already
johnny replied as kindly as he could
it's just that it's a t-shirt
you don't press t-shirts you don't put
starch in t-shirts buddy
but the creases are sharp aren't they
already replies wondering what on earth
the problem could be
the creases are sharp johnny concedes
but that's not the point
you don't put military creases in
t-shirts i've told you this before
already but why
cotton holds the starch really well
johnny starts to get frustrated again
he's been down this road before
many many times
look cleaner i know that you always tell
me that and i always tell you you just
don't starch and press t-shirts because
because you just don't do it
mom likes hers pressed
johnny lets out a sigh
already realizes he's gone too far
listen artie i get it but i'm not mom
and i don't want my t-shirts to be
starched and pressed it's a black
sabbath t-shirt
i just wear it out with a pair of jeans
okay can you just give me give them a
simple wash and dry from now on please
low heat tumble dry already asks
wanting to get a good procedure locked
down
johnny smiles
yeah already
i think that would be perfect
thanks bud
i can do it now already offers
i gotta go oh okay it won't happen again
johnny
thanks artie johnny said with a smile
and johnny already asks
what
i'm sorry
it's okay bud
it's okay
johnny feels a little bad as already
walks away
they are brothers
they even look a little alike it isn't
too much of a stretch to see the similar
genes
dark hair
blue eyes
pronounced eyebrows
but that is where the similarities end
after all
artie is
different a little pudgy
glasses
it is possible to tell from looking at
his face that something isn't quite
right
there are medical names that could be
assigned but most of those wouldn't
quite hit the mark
he's older than johnny by six years but
his
peculiarities keep him living at home
johnny on the other hand doesn't have an
excuse to still be living at home other
than artie
and his mom
they both need him around
that's what he tells himself anyway
johnny's bedroom is the same room he has
always had
mattress on the floor
no box spring no bed frame
posters of rock bands on the wall from
when he was younger
black sabbath
motorhead
led zeppelin ac dc
some muscle cars too
he hadn't bothered to take them down as
he outgrew them
he also hadn't bothered to clean his
room very often
clothes remnants of food and beer cans
on the floor
this was all a stark contrast to artie's
room clinically clean
with the bed tightly made
and then there are the walls of ardy's
room in their curious decor
the walls neatly display pictures of
clothes
washing machines and dryers
there are brochures about various lines
of laundry equipment on his little desk
some of the more colorful ones are also
hanging on the wall
there are also coupons for laundry
detergents fabric softeners and stain
removal products on the desk in an
envelope
the source of his nickname
cleaner
is no mystery at all
artie likes to clean
laundry
to be exact
that right there is the opening
to a new book
a new book called
final spin
which was written
by
me
and it is a novel
i guess that's what it says on the cover
sure
but it's also kind of a poem it's also
kind of a manuscript i don't really
i don't really know 100 what to call it
but it's not normal in the way that it
is written
and
so
as far as the storyline goes it's
i was thinking about this i think it's a
little bit of an alternate
autobiography of source have you ever
heard of alternate history books
so it's where they take some event in
the past and they change it you know
what if the nazis won right what if the
south won the civil war they they call
them alternate history books
so i was kind of thinking this is almost
like an alternate biography in a way
maybe not specifically but maybe some of
my friends some of the experiences we
had with my life if i'd taken some
different turns along the way
well i didn't know this guy's name is
johnny the guy's name is johnny
yeah and but then there's like you're
gonna see as we talk through this
there's some composite characters and
it's almost like everyone's a composite
character what do you mean composed
meaning different people from my past
kind of
assembled together maybe two people that
acted a certain way or one
characteristic from someone maybe a
little bit of a characteristic from me
[Music]
[Applause]
so
that was kind of the starting point
these kind of these kind of humans and
you put them in this situation so so
what is the book about let me i'm going
to start off by reading a review
of the book the first review to come out
about the book and this review came from
from something called publishers weekly
which is a which is a publishing trade
magazine that's been around since 1872
and the subtitle of this thing is the
international news magazine of book
publishing and book selling
this is the heavy hitter of this
industry
uh since the 1940s the book review
section
has sort of become the the center of the
magazine and the online website and it
carries a lot of weight
and and truly ultimately determines a
lot of what you read
depending on how it does and how how
this
publication talks about it the what's
interesting is the reviews in publishers
weekly are anonymous
they're short
they're blunt
and oftentimes to the point of being
brutal you can see that the people that
write them
can be harsh
and they're usually crafty writers so
they're harsh in a pretty savage way i
was reading a little bit about it one
author said a negative review is never
pleasant but publishers weekly reviews
have a particularly heart-stopping
quality and this guy wrote a piece i
didn't write down his name but it was
how he got a bad review and just what it
felt like
um
now
as i said this book is
it's different it's not a normal book
it's hard to classify the form that i
wrote it in
and i've written a bunch of other books
before um
some best-selling books new york times
bestselling books but here's the thing
those books were of a different genre
right and that means a big that means a
lot in this world
in the in the publishing world in the
literature world
i've written a bunch of these you know
non-fiction adult books that's what i've
written and i've written children's
fiction books right but neither of those
are fiction adult books
so it's like saying well i played
professional football
so i can play professional baseball too
it's sort of like saying that which we
know
doesn't really work that way
and most people can't handle that
transition and don't handle that
transition so going into this going into
writing the novel
right i got warned ever tell you about
this probably
i got warned by my publisher
by my i got warned by my editor i got
warned by my agent
they were
they were i think
a little bit trying to talk me out of it
right they're saying it's a different
world and they don't care what you've
done before and they might they might
actually hold your other books against
you they kind of say that kind of thing
right and you should just maybe stay in
your lane
which by the way i got that about my
kids books too
uh but
this story
is one of the stories that's in my head
and i got a lot of stories in my head
and this was the one that bubbled the
surface that needed to get out so i got
it out and this is what publishers
weekly
had to say so here we go
from the critics
final spin a novel by jocko willing
former navy seal and children's book
author willink
way of the warrior kids series marks his
adult fiction debut with the downbeat
and gripping story of a group of
characters abandoned by the american
dream
at age 23 johnny cares for his alcoholic
mother and mentally challenged brother
artie while holding down a dead end job
as a stock boy at a big box store
artie is obsessed with clean clothes and
when the laundromat where he works is
slated to be sold
johnny decides to buy the business in
order to keep artie employed
to come up with the forty thousand
dollars he needs johnny and his best
friend goat
decide to rob the safe at their store
hand off the money to the owner
then hightail it to mexico
they get the money
but the getaway scheme is flawed from
the start and johnny and goat quickly
have the state police on their trail
to make matters worse johnny is forced
to say goodbye to his girlfriend jessica
who has just found out she is pregnant
willing tells his story in quick blasts
of haiku-like writing
and they give the example here johnny on
the customers at his workplace quote
people
flesh-covered robot beings in need of
fuel and meaning
they find both here
end quote
with dialogue reminiscent of early david
mehmet
told with a gritty simplicity
this retains a hold on the reader right
through to the inevitable tragic climax
so uh that's the plot of the book
and that's the impression that they got
at publishers weekly which was a
really uh an awesome review i was
definitely
very stoked to read that as was my
literary agent as was my publisher as
was my editor everyone thinks you're
rolling the dice everyone's nervous
they're scared well yeah you kind of are
rolling the dice but
the nature of dice is you win and you
lose yeah you know a lot of times what
people worried about is the losing part
yeah but there is the winning part yep
now so they compare me they compare the
the
[Music]
uh writing
or at least the dialogue to
yeah the dialogue and i want to give
myself too much credit here but they
they compare the dialogue to david
mamet
who is
well straight up he's a pulitzer
prize-winning freaking author uh he's a
playwright he's a film director director
a screenwriter he's written all kinds of
stuff
you've heard of glenn gary glenn ross
yes sir yep he wrote that
yeah
coffee's for closers always be closing
uh speed the plow he wrote the
screenplay for the postman always rings
twice
little jack nicholson uh the verdict the
untouchables hoffa wag the dog hannibal
he wrote and directed things change
homicide oleano the winslow boy
state in maine sparta just a bunch of
stuff what i'm saying is that this guy's
a highly respected and accomplished
writer definitely i was
very pleasantly surprised and humbled to
be compared to him in any way so we
we're off to a strong start we're
feeling good about it so far much
appreciated
uh because this is a different world
so
it's interesting um appreciate yeah
people if you if you want to get the
book that will be awesome
and it's not a complete dud we'll say
that
so
now this is an interesting we're going
to get into the book a little bit
which is going to be a little bit tricky
because i don't want to ruin the story
story spoiler spoiler alert so i'm going
to keep it
a little bit focused on not going too
much into it but at the same time
getting into the characters a little bit
so
the characters
let's start with this guy artie
so we got this guy artie who
you already heard about he's got some
kind of mental challenges which i don't
name in the book and the reason i didn't
name them in the book is because
a lot of times i've met people in my
life where i know that they have some
kind of mental challenge but
i don't know what it is i'm not a doctor
there's no they're not wearing a label
on their
hat that says whatever mental challenge
they've got
and so i didn't want a label you know i
didn't want to throw a label on there
this is the particular
situation that this person's in and the
other thing is i you know people have
such a wide variety of mental challenges
that
you don't know what you're going to get
[Music]
so where did this character came from
well i this is a
very direct
story i worked at wendy's
hell yeah yeah i don't know if that did
i don't know if that warrants a hell
yeah but i worked at wendy's
and when i worked at wendy's you've been
a wendy's before right yes sir i have
which
let's face it kind of props to wendy's
wendy's
when he serves it up and i used to
i used to get my chow one at wendy's
when i was a teenager
well at this wendy's where i worked it
was there's a salad bar you know they
have a salad bar at wendy's i don't they
still have a salad bar winnie's not that
i know if i don't i don't know so back
in the day
back in the day they had a salad bar at
wendy's and the person that ran the
salad bar
that took care of the salad bar that
resupplied the
peach slices and the caesar salad
dressing was this woman who clearly had
she was probably
i'm going to say 55 maybe 60 years old
so an older woman
thin
short hair her name was a gene
and
she obviously had you know it seemed
like some kind of perhaps autism
but again i don't know she's not wearing
a label
but she was super into the salad bar she
was probably the best one of the best
employees ever
she loved this salad bar she wanted to
be squared away she was out there with a
washcloth wiping up if anybody if you
spilled a drop of salad dressing on your
on your maneuver from the spoon to the
plate she was honest she was standing by
with a rag she was gonna wipe that up
like almost bumping into you but she
also knew that that wasn't correct so
she'd give me you know three quarters of
a second to take one step towards the
croutons and then she was in there
getting on it
so
she's there and she's working and she
loved it i mean like she was obsessed
with it and no one would talk to her
right everyone was kind of mean to her
right because you could make fun of her
and she was an easy target
and i was cool to her you know i'd
always say hi hi gene how you doing you
know trying to talk to her a little bit
and every time i would start a
conversation with her hey gene how are
you you know hey gene how's it going
today and she'd be like i just opened up
a new can of of
of croutons in the new a new can of
sliced peaches they're going to be so
good and i'd be oh that's awesome
you know
and i'd say oh you know it's your like
lunch break
hey jean are you going to take a lunch
break yeah first i'm going to get more
sliced onions out here and
have you seen the onions they're so
fresh
she was just fired up man
to the point where
i was torn
between
thinking
if it was
an abusive situation where she was being
taken advantage of
to where
the others like complete opposite was
she just were they so
was she so lucky to be there and happy
that they hired her and like here she
was with this job
so that was one part of it the other
part of it that struck me that stuck
with me for my whole life
is that she was
happy
right so here i am this young freaking
punk ass kid and i'm there with other
punk ass kids that are working at
wendy's and everyone's kind of miserable
right
did you ever work at a fast food joint
do you ever work at a restaurant i did
not work at a restaurant the bar
nightclub was the closest but even being
a bouncer in a barn nightclub is not
that's kind let's let's face it that's
like a little bit kind of cool
yeah a little bit right well you have a
little power there's also a bar back at
one point at other clubs and bartenders
so it's it's service for sure but it's
different you're currently it's
different it's a little bit cool
yes to be a bouncer at a club yes sir
right
i mean that can be a definitely a cool
job
it's not cool
to work at wendy's
running the grill running the salad bar
you're not happy about it there's no
benefits
zero
you know you other than you're getting
paid money which is kind of cool
so what struck me what i always
remembered is we're all kind of
miserable even this is what i also
remember like the the general manager
and i don't remember his name
but he was like work he was one of those
guys that was just a work working you
know work you know just always pissed
off about something like hey you know
always mad yeah so even the owner i mean
he was i don't know if he's the owner i
don't think he's the owner but he's
definitely the general manager
he might have even been the franchise
owner or something because he was in
there all the time yeah but you know he
had to be making legitimate money
because when you when you're a general
manager one of those you're making good
money but he was freaking miserable so
i'm thinking to myself everyone here has
missed every single person here
100 i mean how many employees they
probably have
probably a total of
35 to 40 employees you know day shift
night shift
you know
everyone everyone's part-time you know
so no one's really working so there's
like probably 40 employees there total
and every single one of us was miserable
and hated life
except for jean
and she was smiling and she was into it
and she was amped
so
i took that idea
and
the reason i ended up with laundry is
because i worked at all right with the
place where i used to go to the
laundromat in san diego
had this the people that owned the
laundromat
the the they were from asia
and the wife didn't speak english
but the husband would be kind of be
there but the the the wife didn't speak
english but she'd come out and talk to
me
in
i don't even know where she was from but
she would talk to me and smile and laugh
and make jokes
not in english not in english
but they were funny
they were so funny that i did laugh i
would laugh i would be with my wife i
would laugh and one not even know what
it was about you know she might point at
like you know a pile of clothes and say
something
in whatever language she was talking to
and then just start laughing my wife and
i would just laugh
it had to be pretty funny for her to get
that much joy out of it right
so
i don't know that i landed on laundry
um
so there we go there we get artie that
kind of wraps up this guy already as a
character where he came from so now we
get this other character johnny
which as you said yeah it's my it's i
guess my
my real first name is john so do we get
to johnny from there kind of but i don't
know
maybe just the generic of
[Music]
of the name johnny more than anything
else but
probably the strongest
influence on this character
is a kid that i grew up with a kid named
jeff lang who i've talked about on this
on this podcast before
so jeff lang was like my best friend
from maybe
third grade
maybe sec no probably second second
first or second grade
until
seventh grade
and in fifth grade
we we were in the same classroom
together
all day
because that's before you start going to
different classes right so fifth grade
we were in the same class you know
sitting next to each other and we were
we were um troublemakers right just
always getting in trouble
always causing problems always you know
laughing when we shouldn't be laughing
just doing stuff that we shouldn't have
been doing
but he was always a little bit more
he had a little bit he had a little bit
less obedience in him i didn't have much
he had even less obedience in him so
like at that point when the teacher
would
threaten oh you you to be quiet are you
going to the office
that was he could i got checked by that
jeff wouldn't get checked by that he go
next level get sent to the office right
so he had a little bit extra and he was
super funny
i mean hilarious
you know kind of an athletic stud
which which what does that mean that
means when you're in fifth grade you
kind of kick ass at dodge ball right you
play kickball and he's really good and
run faster so yeah just fast and all
that stuff just a good a really good
athlete better than me
funnier than me
tall you know just just a good
he was just kind of like a little bit
better than me and everything
and he also had a little bit of extra
rebelliousness
so
as we got older
i started kind of we started started to
deviate in our lives together um you
know we were we were still always
friends but he started
like drinking started doing drugs
started listening to
i guess he went down like the kind of
hippie music drugs that kind of thing
and i was going into the hardcore music
and more like the straight edge thing
and so our past really kind of deviated
but we were still friends because we
were such good friends for so long that
it doesn't matter what he's doing and
what i'm doing we're still friends we
just have this you know huge common
connection
and as we got so so as we got older he
went really you know i i don't even know
if he i don't even remember if he
graduated high school
because he went hard you know doing
drugs
and drinking and just doing that whole
thing
um and not not a bad person that's just
what he was doing and still i'd see him
see him in town we'd you know we'd
always connect we'd always just had that
friendship
and i remember i joined the military i
joined the navy
and you know a small town and he kind of
knew
he had heard what was going on and then
i saw him
and i remember he i he said something to
me like because you know when we were
little kids we would play army all the
time right when you're look when you're
seven years old 10 years old 12 years
old and you live in the woods you're
playing army right you're putting you're
burning a cork and putting making your
face black and putting camo on and
shooting bb guns at each other that's
what we did we would shoot bb guns at
each other
and every time you got hit you had to
take a layer of clothing off
and i remember the red rider it makes a
little boom when it it's like
this it's spring activated oh yeah yeah
and because you know we try and put
limits on the number of pumps you could
put on the pump actually it happens
but i remember the red rider because you
you could hear it
and then it would hit you
so
so you know he was into the same kind of
stuff i was and then as we got older we
deviated
so i see him
the last time i see him
before i leave for the navy
he's
you know clearly
not on a great path
and he said something to me along the
lines of
he said yeah you're joining the navy i
said yeah
and i don't even remember if we if he
knew what a seal was i think he kind of
did
the only i kind of did at that time i
mean no one knew too much about it
but he's i remember he said something
like hey i wish i could go with you
and i was like you can bro let's go and
i could see like maybe that could
and he said i can't he's i can't i can't
something like i can't anymore like he
knew he was kind of too far gone
to correct the path that he was on
so
i end up going the navy and i was going
through seal training and i was
probably around
just before hell week maybe just after a
week i forget but i called my parents to
check in i talked to my mom
and i found out that jeff had killed
himself
and he had broken up with his girlfriend
at the time and he killed himself
and that was
you know just just uh
very
sad
because well i think what made it the
most sad to me was that he had gone down
this path
and he had way more potential than i had
as a human
and and
it was all gone
and that was really sad and then and
when i looked him up you know this is
one the last time i recorded that i
talked about him on on this podcast was
a couple years ago i had googled him
just googled his name which
you can google people from you know
1745 and there's some
record and there's some
you know
genealogy report about who they were and
you'd google someone from 1942
and there's you know an obituary about
who they were and i googled his name and
there was like nothing
nothing
which is just horrible because he was
freaking hilarious smart
on just an awesome guy
and and quite uh i didn't mention this
but the book you know the dedication of
the book it just says for jeff lang
so
that was sort of
a lot of where this character johnny
came from somebody with
kind of potential and um
just
stuck
made bad choices
made maybe not bad choices but different
choices maybe had some bad luck thrown
in there
lived his life
so that's johnny you hear about these
two
um
next up
you get a guy named goat who's johnny's
best friend i'm gonna go to uh page
seven here
in the book
nice shirt man
goat says with a smile as he sees
johnny's starched black sabbath t-shirt
its military creases running from each
shoulder down to the waist up yours
johnny replies that cotton really holds
the crease doesn't it
yeah it does johnny says you couldn't
iron them out or anything i tried but
damn he uses an industrial press and he
looks at me like i'm ripping his heart
out what can i say my brother is crazy
yeah but that son of a [__] can iron
some shirts can he he sure as hell can
you want another one what time do we
have to be at work goat asks
not until 10 30. [__] let's do this two
more lucy johnny says to the barn maid
bb's bar
dingy working class watering hole
cheap vinyl seats
even cheaper drinks
goat is about the same age as johnny
though he looks a little younger
his dark skin has an almost childlike
texture his black hair looks as if it is
always organized
regardless of what he has been doing
his eyes are dark and deep
he is handsome
he too
has that look about him that says he
shouldn't be here
shouldn't be in a dead end job
shouldn't be in a dead end bar
shouldn't be in a dead end life
but he is
so there's goat
full name george martinez
that is johnny's best friend
and again
this guy is kind of a composite
character
of
friends that i had grown up the uh story
takes place in southern california
um
so he's a mexican kid i grew up with a
bunch of white people primarily but
when you're out in california you see
the
there's really no distinction between
you know different people
um
and that's just another kid another kid
that has a bunch of potential another
kid that's talented another kid that's
smart another kid that's handsome
and another kid that's kind of stuck in
a dead-end scenario with what i say
dead-end job dead and bar dead in life
right
that's where we end up
that's where we're at
and
we were talking before the podcast about
the young
uh i think i think carrie was saying you
remember what it was like when you were
younger and it was just all in kind of
like you're just on board right now
down for the cause right
down for the cause
and that was
the characteristic that i kind of tried
to throw in here with goat was that
characteristic of being down for the
cause and what's cool what when you when
you talked about johnny being based on
me
um
there's parts definitely elements of me
in johnny for sure but one of the
elements that's that's from me in goat
is just down for the cause i mean the
stuff that you do in your
16 17 18 and then when i got in the navy
you're 19 20 years old guess what oh
that's what as you like to say echo
that's what we're doing yep down for the
cause we're down yeah we're ready to go
well with that is that what we're doing
hey all right once you kind of slip that
switch
that's why man the young the young men
in the world
they'll do some crazy [__] sometimes
because they're just ready to rock and
roll
ready to rock and roll so there's your
two main characters
and
again one of the things one of the
immediate feedback points
when i submitted the manuscript
was how about some more character
development
right
and what i said is you already know
these characters we already know these
characters we grow up with these
characters everybody knows these people
everybody knows these people we all know
them yeah we are them in many ways so i
was like what yeah what else do i need
to tell you
what else do i need to tell you you know
these people i know these people
there's your character development look
around
you uh
you started this with artie
and that's one of the first things that
jumped out on me where it's like not
only do i know who that guy is i've
known a guy or girl like that since i
was a little kid and it's just he's just
there he's down for his cause some
negative some positive some are like
angry at everyone somewhere just happy
to see every you know like but but
really you know not a kind of in a
generic almost kind of way i mean it's
more particular because because the book
and everything right but you know that
guy totally know that guy that's the
first thing that jumped out of me for
already
oh yeah and how many arties have you
known about
12 i would say yeah and but they fit
that in one way another little different
flavor yeah for sure you know oh man i'm
sure i could go deep into it too where
some people would tease them just like
you're your girl jean same exact thing
man and they're everywhere so it's like
yeah you know we all know artie yeah i
think most of us we all know an arty we
all know gene we all know johnny we all
know goat yes sir these are our people
and there's the character development
yeah and look obviously there's more
character development that goes on but
you know
for me to take the time
to explain this this is one thing you're
going to notice when you read this book
is i'm not i'm trying not to waste any
time yeah i'm trying not to waste any
words
i'm trying to get you there
it get you there
get you into this as quick as possible
and allow you to to utilize what you
already know as a person yeah
to to put the context around what's
happening use the schema i was reading
this book and they they went deep in the
word schema you know
that's what you're doing
use stuff that you already know to
describe so you know some something new
right interesting and you use like
you do this in real life too where you
use less words than necessary kind of
thing and it's weird because it makes
you kind of go like deep in your own
head almost when you read it like even
that one uh when you're describing um
people you know me however you described
in the news just like
it's like
you didn't do this like the opposite of
that the opposite of that is like some
grandiose thing where it's like you know
one after another the people piled in
like this and like that and then this
person and it's the but no you did the
exact opposite but meanwhile you get the
same effect but it's more like in your
own
head like real real personal kind you
know there's something i talk about with
leadership it's minimum force required
yeah right i as a leader want to use the
minimum force
to get you to do what i want you to do
to get you to do what we need to do
right minimum force required i don't
want to say hey echo here's what you
need to do i might say heck what do you
think about doing this and you're like
oh that yeah that's probably be good
right i want to use the minimum force
i try and write
i tried to write this book
where
the the feeling is there with the
minimum amount of words
get the point across with the minimum
amount of words
it does add drama to him let's admit
that because even in real life this book
is a sight
like it's more dramatic that way well i
also say all the time the less you talk
the more people listen yeah yeah and i
say that all the time i give that as
leadership counsel hey if you're in
there and you got something to say in a
meeting and you say it in 14 sentences
and it takes you seven minutes yeah
maybe 14 seconds maybe maybe you maybe
it takes you seven minutes to say
something
that you could have said in
14 seconds the 14 second route was way
is way preferred of course and it's
gonna have so much more impact yes sir
but let's face it the the added
specifically added drama
is undeniable
like so if if we're here i don't know
let's say we had to i don't know make
key chains or something and there was
like a hundred thousand key chains that
needed to be be made and we get here at
five p.m or whatever and and i ask you
and you're like yeah we need to get
these done or whatever and then i look
at them and go hey are we gonna do all
these tonight and and there's two
different scenarios where you could be
like you know what yeah we're going to
we're going to get all these done
tonight or you could just look at me
i know already the answer is [__] yes
yeah it's hell yes but it's way more
dramatic yeah you didn't even say
anything didn't say anything exactly
right or you could pull which would you
typically do you'll just say yes and
that's it
i want more i want you to make me feel
good i want to but it's just this big
black hole of of nothingness that i'm
just left with except for yes like with
that you you gotta make of it whatever
you're gonna make of it but yes you know
so it's like yeah way more dramatic
it's good though so that's what the book
is written like um
i we're going to roll into i'm just
trying to give some of the characters
right some of the some of the characters
here's the
i guess this is our leading
female character in the book here we go
she is a pretty but tough looking girl
thick black hair that wants to curl but
is for the most part straightened by its
own weight and volume
pale skin
dark eyes
eyes with a hint of fight left in them
but most of the fight is gone
worn away by long hours and hard work
and worn away by the reality of life
jessica
where have you been she asks
working where else johnny responds
defensively you can't call or anything
sorry he replies i'm a prick yeah you
are she says
you never held that against me before
don't start now you buy me a drink and
i'll forgive you lucy soco and coke
johnny shouts to the bar made so cullen
coke got it the bartender responds
how's work johnny asks
although he knows the answer
the usual mark's an [__] everybody
comes into that place as a [__]
[__]
and i do what i do smile and kiss their
ass why don't you quit johnny asks
it's an earnest question even though the
answer is known by him
she knows the answer too
she also has the same question why don't
you quit your [__] job stock boy
ouch
thanks johnny mudders dejected
well i mean [__] of course i'd quit that
job same as you but who's gonna pay the
rent
the bartender approaches them and places
the southern comforting coke in front of
jessica
soco and coke she says matter of fact
thanks lucy johnny tells her thanks
johnny jessica says to johnny
anything for you darling he says with a
smile
great you're horny she says hey he
replies defensively i'm just don't worry
i am too she says with a smile
so there's jessica
um
again where does jessica come from kind
of a composite character
of
growing up of traveling
going to different towns different
cities
restaurants bars you know she's a
waitress
um i've known
many jessica's
in my time and like you said i think
we've all known plenty of jessica's and
and look she's hard-working um she's
determined but she's up against the odds
and she's also productive
and you've learned this in the book
she's a product of some bad decisions or
at least some decisions that aren't
great ones right
so she kind of ends up in her
stuck in this position as well and and
to uh quote harvey keitel
from reservoir dogs yes sir waitressing
is the number one job for female
non-college graduates in this country
and i always i always you know because i
worked in restaurants man
that's a freaking hard job
and you got to smile
right well yeah kind of customer service
is great got a smile
so not only are you working a hard job
and people are treating you bad in some
cases yeah where this
this isn't cooked good enough
by the way if you if you ever are
serving me and i return something to the
kitchen it is totally jacked up because
if it's not totally jacked up i'm just
gonna like just gonna get it done
i mean you gotta give me a raw bleeding
piece of meat if you think i'm gonna
return to the kitchen
what about the wrong thing someone gives
you straight up the wrong thing they
mess your order up wrong thing is it
something i'm down with
you know
is it okay is it like hey i ordered the
ribeye get a piece of prime rib cool
i'll eat it what if you get a fish
i'm probably going back
i'll be cool about it yeah i'll probably
just say you know what i might do in
that situation this is how nice i am
really like yeah
yeah no because i'd probably be like hey
you know i'm also interested in getting
a steak can you bring me a rib eye you
can both go with this oh my man yeah and
maybe maybe put that in a
doggy bag or something do you uh do you
on the inside do you actually feel bad
that you have to do it like yes you have
to you feel bad huh yeah i'm with you i
don't like um
i don't like messing with waitresses i
don't like you know anybody in service
right
you know anybody in service i don't like
being that guy yeah the
the proverbial guy right that's like hey
yeah man can you hurry up with that yeah
yeah uh you know i'm the guy that'd be
like hey you know i guess i guess i'm
not drinking water tonight
i haven't seen old homegirl in a while
um
but hey you know when someone does good
service like i'm i'm definitely going to
take care of them too yeah yeah that's
good you know that's what we're doing
but that's jessica right
we get this she's sort of she's honestly
she's kind of like a female johnny
in a way right she's smart she's
good-looking
she's witty but
maybe not the best choices maybe she
didn't roll out in the best environment
and that's addressed too in the book you
know there's some there's a level of
ownership that gets you know
responsibility for our actions and she's
the one that kind of
pushes that like hey you can sit around
here because
at a certain point i don't want to get
too much into it but johnny starts
saying well you know we didn't i didn't
i i i didn't have the right upbringing
and all this and she's like hey dude
no one made you quit
school no one made you do this no one
made you did those things
um
but like you said these are these are
these are his people these are normal
people these are people in the world
these are people i grew up with these
are my friends to this day
uh people i met along the way
now
that's kind of your main character
there's one more character i want to
introduce
and look there's a bunch there are a lot
more characters in the book i shouldn't
say a lot more i tried to limit the
number of characters as much as possible
right i don't want to have this big
complex
uh
storyline that's hard to follow i wanted
it to be when you heard someone i want
you just to know who it is and boom
you're locked
that was my goal simplicity
um
there's another character
that i i do want to bring up because he
does
he's got some he's got some a little bit
of impact and this character as you
heard from the review from the publisher
weekly review johnny and goat they work
at a big box store
and their boss is this guy named gerald
lundstrom
jerry also known as jerry and they call
him
the weasel that's what they call them so
let's get an introduction to
gerald lundstrom the weasel let's get an
introduction to the big box store
to what their jobs are and what they do
there
they're stock boys so here we go
you would think americans
survived on [__] mayonnaise goat says
disgusted no [__]
stock boys
boxes
tile floor and industrial shelves
detergent
electronics
pretty much anything can be found here
every day from the time the doors open
until they close there are customers
here
buying milk and batteries and toilet
paper and garbage bags
tomatoes popcorn salami
people can buy anything here
and they do
consumption in massive quantities to
fill their massive bellies and run up
their massive credit card debt
people
flesh covered robot beings in need of
fuel and meaning
they find both here
i mean honestly who the [__] needs a
half a gallon of miracle whip for their
house goat asks earnestly trying to
comprehend this madness well obviously a
bunch of people need it all this will be
gone in a couple of days
goat shakes his head what the hell did
they do with it do they put it in their
cereal or something i think they butter
their wives up with it god damn that's
[__] disgusting yeah it is johnny
agrees
from the end of the aisle a loud
high-pitched voice breaks their
conversation
jerry the night manager
you guys need to stop talking and get
that stuff stacked up less talking and
more stocking
we've still got pickles mustard crisco
and can ham
i got your canned ham goat whispers
under his breath
jerry walks toward goat and johnny
thin
late 30s
smoker
greasy hair
beige levi dockers
polo shirt
yellow
gold colored necklace with cross gold
colored watch
fake
what did you say
jerry asks aggressively
goats stand up goat stands up straight
and belts out i said i got your canned
ham
jerry shakes his head he tries to think
of an original comeback but he can't
think of anything good
he resorts to all he knows well you just
keep running your mouth like that and
we'll see if you ever make supervisor
not wanting to engage in a verbal battle
jerry quickly walks away
goat stands there shaking his head
mother [__] he says quietly then
unable to contain himself shouts
supervise this you weasel-looking
[__]
johnny looks at him
i'd [__] kill myself if i ever made
supervisor at this [__]
yeah and that [__] prick walking
around like he's [__] steve jobs
loser [__] loser
at least he's easy to rip off johnny
concedes
yeah he's got that going for him
i'm getting a couple of bottles of jack
tonight goat says
i'm getting the nastiest rot gut gin i
can find
so
there you go
that's the uh manager
have you ever had a manager like like my
boy like the weasel yes sir god
do i need to
do character development or do we know
who jerry the weasel lundstrom is right
we're going to use the schema on that
one yeah for sure and um
i had so much fun writing that dialogue
i heard you chuckling i heard k-dog
behind the scenes over there chuck
because i was rolling some of that
just because that's what it's like right
you know you're 22 23 years old you have
you have a crap job
you know you know dave burke good deal
yeah he was a stock boy at
target yeah and he was a stock boy when
he was at target and he was like 15.
and he's like you nailed you nailed that
dialogue you nailed those characters and
i go i was there i said how can that be
you weren't like that and he was no i
wasn't like that i was 15 just trying to
do a good job and trying to get money he
goes but i worked with guys
that shouldn't have been working there
that were 22 23 24 years old
and i would hear them talking and you
freaking nailed it yeah these guys talk
to each other and talk [__]
um
so
we all know managers like this
kind of a
stereotypical manager um
and that's the way the world kind of
gets put together for this book now
again i don't want to spend i don't want
to start covering the plot of the book
you kind of heard it from the review a
little bit of what happens in the plot
you don't get the whole deal but that's
sort of the direction we're heading in
got to get the book to get there but
i did want to kind of just talk about
some of the
themes some of the other themes that are
in the book
one of them is is
kind of this
idea of being obsessed with random
things which we all certainly do i do
we all end up obsessed with these random
things and if you look at it from the
outside it doesn't make any sense
so jiu-jitsu
um surfing
archery
uh rock climbing
music guitars
nascar
lawn
super into your lawn
right super into fishing super into yoga
super into cooking super into grill like
there's all these things that people
just get into
and
that level of obsession
could be about anything right and that
was that was one of the fun things that
i had with artie was i was thinking what
would be the most random kind of thing
that you could be obsessed with how
about laundry
doing laundry but there's not that much
difference between being obsessed with
doing laundry and and archery yeah and
i'm believe me i'm pretty obsessed with
archery i spend a bunch of time doing it
i spend money on it like
why
man i could be making super clean
clothes jiu jitsu hey we're super
ninjutsu yeah we could talk about this
freaking skill and this and that but
at this point we have kind of the basic
skills that we need to defend ourselves
we're just doing it yeah it's for a
whole nother reason right
lawns right yeah like lawn care people
get fired up for that stuff oh yeah
so that's something that we do
it's an underlying theme in the book is
man think about what you're doing what
are you obsessed with why are you
obsessed with it yeah we get into some
weird stuff yeah
that is weird um consumerism
buying stuff that's another thing we do
you wrap that you wrap the obsession
around also around consumerism buying
stuff
and
if you've ever been to a big box store
which i certainly have been to many
and
still go to
or i should say still shop at because
because i don't go to them very often my
wife my wife kind of gets that done
but
you go into those places and it's we
consume a lot of stuff
right and here's here's what i think is
interesting and nowadays you know this
this this book takes place
in the early 90s late 80s i'm going to
say early 90s
so there's no cell phones
um
but one thing that i've found that i
think i believe and you can tell me what
you think
i think we i think have you ever built
something
yes sir i have and it gave that took you
some time and effort mm-hmm
what's the biggest thing you've ever
built big biggest one yeah i don't know
but
that wasn't that did not come from ikea
yeah
so what okay so i i don't know the
biggest thing that's gonna take a while
for me to think of but the thing that
did jump out at me was i used to make
slingshots when i was a kid okay so
um you'd go down in our in my case i'd
go down the valley the canyon whatever
um and you'd find a guava tree i like
the guava tree wood uh you and then you
find where there's like a perfect y it
can't be like too narrow of a split
right gotta be and it can't be too wide
either there's a lot of those
you gotta find the perfect one
boom you cut it you cut it all three
spots and you bring it back
you you skin it
let it dry for a little bit like a few
days or whatever um i used to this is
when i went extra on it i'd sand it down
so it looks kind of cool
oh you can put finish on it i never
really did that um and then you go by
it's called surgical tubing yeah stuff
then you uh yeah you attach them and
then you cut off the tongue of your shoe
like an old shoe or whatever you cut it
off and then poke the two holes use a
knife or even like a whole puncher it's
harder to do the whole puncher but you
you know you do the two uh holes attach
the surgical tube tubing what i would do
is i do this
circle the surgical tubing go in the
hole curl back i'd super glue it
together
wrap it with thread not too tight
because it might start cutting into when
it starts to oxidize a little bit and
then tape like small piece of tape so
it'd be super strong super strong the
same thing both sides are all four
attachments and boom there you go looks
nice too how did you feel when you were
complete bro amazing that's why i do a
bunch of them like i don't need like
five sling shots but yeah oh yeah i got
two or three going so i think there's
some i don't know there's probably some
chemical dopamine hit or whatever that
you get when you actually do something
when you build something like i've built
so
like like redoing my house like reema
like ripping out gutting my hat
one time i did
my kitchen
and i gutted it
in 72 hours i gutted the whole thing
demoed it
got it out redid the electrical read the
plumbing
put in a sub box what's that called i
put in a a sub box for the electrical i
forget what it's called uh but i put in
like a whole new electrical system
and then i dry walled it
and i did that all in 72 hours
and but you feel like accomplishment
right
yeah
building like fences at my houses
building
i remodeled my other house so so like
these major projects
you feel this good sense of satisfaction
when you're done
well in the modern world we do a lot
less
of that right so
so you can replace that sort of
satisfaction
by clicking
on the amazon whatever buy now right and
all of a sudden you feel like but the
thing is since you didn't put much
effort into it it's not that gratifying
so you want to do it again yeah yeah so
i think that's why people roll into
freaking costco
they roll into costco and they roll out
with way more stuff because they just
walk through those aisles getting that
dopamine hit dopamine dopamine hit
they'll be hit
because they feel like they
built
that thing or they harvested
it's the same thing when you go hunting
and you like harvest the meat it's super
gratifying
super
like 1 000 times more gratifying
than buying a steak at the store and
believe me buying a steak at the store
is kind of gratifying too but you get
that dopamine you're like oh yeah then
when this is gonna be so good but it's
way less so you can buy another one
right you know and then you buy this and
you buy that right yeah that's weird huh
so it's kind of like when you kind of uh
maybe cut it all the way down to what
the hell is going on with that little
transaction it's like you know like
almost for like a better way of putting
it in the wild or in the you know nature
whatever you put in this work and then
you uh you run through some challenges
you overcome those challenges then you
get the reward right
any pursuit that's sort of the system
and your brain
you know follows along accordingly boom
you put in the work you get obsessive
over it you you run into a challenge you
overcome the challenge and you're back
on your path to you know for that main
goal you know and the harder you work
the bigger the reward usually right as
far as in your brain like the bigger the
payoff you know so it's like if you
overcome all these and then you then you
re you finally reap that reward and in
your case it's hunting the elk or you
know whatever whatever the reward is the
prize right there boom there's your your
ultimate satisfying dopamine hit
whatever
but now it's the same thing except you
reduce the work part so much but you
still get the little reward you know but
here's the thing you reduce the work the
reward you get rewarded but it's less
work less reward so what do you do you
do it again less satisfying yeah but you
just do it again oh yeah like call i'm
gonna order this i'm gonna buy that yeah
and so you end up in this sort of weird
cycle of
of satisfaction by just buying stuff
brady and you know and we've talked
about this too brother the people who
make the stores the layout and stuff oh
they know about that kind of stuff
that's why they that's why there's a
thing called impulse buy right so they
put the candy right there by the
checkout stuff that you didn't plan on
getting but it's like oh i'm gonna use
one of those right now you know kind of
a thing it's like an impulse buy you
ever get
i i don't see you doing this but maybe
you do i don't know but you know when
you're shopping on amazon right
and me i i get a lot of carry relate to
this where i get a lot of little cables
and little tools and whatever you know
just for this thing or that thing or
whatever um and then when you check out
or when you add it to the cart they'll
introduce all these other things people
also bought
yeah and then i'm like yeah you sure
you're like double me
oh yeah i could use that never gonna use
it but i could i could imagine myself
using this pair of pliers you know so
many i have two pairs of pliers by the
way already oh but that one with the red
handle and that was kind of dope and it
has a little thing on the side i am the
i am the most i research stuff to the
point where it's stupid you trying to
get me to buy something
i was looking at uh someone's i was
looking at one of my i was looking at
one of my kids
yeah my kids instagram and my my
daughter was like oh i have an
advertisement every third whatever
picture is an advertisement
and i go on that no like oh i hardly
have any and
she's like no way and i showed her and i
have like almost no promoted ads
you know why i never click on them and
they know i'm like low
low conversion
i'm like the lowest conversion ever not
even wasting their money throwing that
thing across in front of me because
you you could have the best freaking
idea in the world and i'm gonna start
like i'm gonna have to research that
yeah i'm surprised amazon just doesn't
check me out without showing me anything
because they're just over don't even try
yeah don't even try not worth it
so that's an underlying theme but here's
here's the here's the kind of the real
um
i don't know maybe it's the maybe it's
the heaviest underlying theme is just
the idea and it is it's about happiness
right
not only about happiness but this sort
of underlying
unhappiness in the world underlying
sadness in the world um
when i was a kid and i was working at
wendy's and i saw jean and i saw that
she was freaking happy
and i knew
that i wasn't
and i didn't even know if i could be
it didn't seem like an achievable thing
it seemed like there was too much
underlying
things in the world that just are gonna
be bad right
um
and i always sense that in the world i
always sensed always i always had this
sense in the world of this underlying
sadness underlying despair this
underlying suffering
and i don't want to use the term
depression because maybe you wrap all
those things together because depression
seems like it's a clinical sort of like
a problem that you treat type thing and
i didn't feel like this was a clinical
problem
it just seemed like life to me
was not gonna go the way you wanted it
to go
for anyone
you're gonna end up in the wrong job
you're gonna end up in the wrong
relationship you're gonna something's
gonna be wrong with your health
um something's gonna be wrong in your
family
but and we're gonna die
and we're all gonna die and before we
die we're gonna suffer
and by the way everyone that you know
and everyone that you love is going to
suffer and die
and so i i would always i kind of had
this
underlying sense of the world
and then i would catch like glimpses of
people that were happy and
sometimes it was someone like gene there
was another guy that worked at a
freaking junkyard
who was kind of jacked especially when i
was younger you know when you were
younger
and in the in the 70s
if someone was jacked in the 70s like it
was a whole
it was like a next level right yeah
because you're you're not used to seeing
people that are jacked at all and
i remember seeing this guy who's worked
at a junkyard
and and he looked happy and i was like
dude this guy's just jacked and just
lifting engine parts around the junkyard
and it seemed like he was happy
so
that's sort of this underlying
theme and i'll tell you like when i got
to the teams thank god
[Music]
when i got to the teams that's when i
started feeling like oh like kind of
happy like this is cool
the people i'm with are kind of cool and
life's not going to be perfect but we're
going to have a good time living this
imperfect life
so i started to get a little bit
relieved of that as i got as i got older
but i think that
you know johnny kind of realizes that
he's not going to be happy
and and this is the other sort of the
other sort of underlying theme
is this idea of of
sacrifice
and
when johnny realizes that he can't be
happy or at least he doesn't think he
can happy
he sees that
you know kind of the way i looked at
jean the wendy's salad bar girl
but that's his brother
and the situation unfolds where he's not
gonna be able to be happy anymore where
where artie is not gonna be happy
anymore and
johnny knows if he makes sacrifices he
could preserve the happiness for his
brother
especially because he's never going to
be happy himself
um
you know i had this conversation with
stoner one time we were out surfing
and he was asking me that he's like bro
i don't know it's like the same thing
he's like bro i'm never gonna how how
are you how am i ever gonna be happy i'm
never gonna be happy you know we're
literally it's like a beautiful
southern california we're out at our
surf spot
for whatever reason there's not many
guys out there's a little offshore
breeze the water's warm it's a you know
chest to head high swell pretty
consistent like it's it doesn't get any
better
and he's out here saying to me like i
don't know how do you ever how you ever
find happiness and i'm like bro this is
it man
this is it right here
and that's what
you know that's what that's what
you have to be able to find
you have to be able to find that
the path that you're on
even though it's challenging even though
they're suffering that's that's the
happiness too
and the sacrifice part is putting others
above yourself you know and obviously on
this podcast we talk about heroes and we
talk to heroes in many cases
and most of the ones that we talk to
here are military people right soldiers
sailors airmen marines
but those aren't the only people
those aren't the only people in the
world that are heroes right and and i'm
not just talking about law enforcement
and you know firefighters and first
responders as well there's all kinds of
people in the world that put others
above themselves
and put other people's happiness above
themselves
and
whether that's mothers and fathers
sisters and brothers and wives and
husbands and friends i mean there's
friends that do that
friends that
put
other people's happiness and other
people's success above themselves
and
really that's
that's the unreal that's one of the
other underlying themes of the book
is and then you know that's that's a
theme that's consistent with all the
books that have written fiction
non-fiction people that are putting
others above themselves
that's what leadership is and ultimately
that's what life is about
so
i think if you can put other others
before yourselves
then if we do that then you can find
some happiness and at a minimum at a
minimum
you can leave the world in better
condition than you found it
if you can pull that off i think if you
can pull that off
then you can die with a clean conscience
and you can die with a smile on your
face
and you can leave a smile on the face of
the people you left behind
and that's a good life
and that is
final spin
uh
so
we can't obviously cover the whole plot
the details what we'll do is maybe in a
year remember what we did with
musashi yeah with musashi so this is
episode
episode 401
that's actually two years isn't it
yeah
we'll give people two years to sort it
out
sure is that long no we do one year so
we do so we say 350.
sure okay we'll go 350. we'll shoot for
350. so 350. we'll do full spoiler we'll
just tell everyone what's going on we'll
take a bunch of questions about the book
um
and
yeah we'll do it again where we can go a
little bit deeper on all the plot
you know as i start getting feedback
from people and people start asking all
those awesome questions that you ask
when you read books and what's this part
about what does this represent
we'll do all that
uh the books for for sale right now
i would order it if i were you why
clearly because you want that first to
dish uh and here's another reason this
is us against the establishment
by the way
this is us against the literary critics
right this is us against the big
publishing companies the media companies
where the outsiders i'm an outsider let
me tell you what i go to new york city
and i roll into those publishing offices
i am an outsider i might as well be
purple
[Music]
uh
because i'm not from that world right
they don't
the interesting thing is i mean i was an
english major in college
they don't know about that
they just look at me think knuckle
dragger
meathead which i take as a compliment
absolutely
um
but yeah they don't want us to win so
join the cause right
let's let's let's let's take the fight
to them
um
get that first edition and here's the
other thing i was planning to do a
speaking thing kind of like jocko live
what we did last year right before covet
hit i was we were booking it up
and the whole freaking
the industry's still paranoid and a
bunch of the venues started getting
crazy with the way they were going to
run them and someone wanted to cancel
and so i said all right fine we'll put
it off so i'm going to do a jocko live
tour with this i don't know what i don't
know what cities i'm going to the only
city i
keep saying i want to go to
is detroit
i just want to go to detroit and by the
way there's so you know jack white is
it's
white stripes oh i'm thinking todd white
um no no i do now yes yeah yeah so he's
got a thing up in
detroit
he's got a
place where he can record
bands
straight to vinyl
oh damn so it just straight to vinyl i
think it's a venue that holds like 50
people oh dude so i want to do jocko
live there i want to record it straight
to the line
yeah and just get it
artisan honestly yeah bro straight to
vinyl
i think it might be the only place in
america where you can do that
that sounds correct and plus the white
stripes are awesome jack white's
freaking awesome so that would be sick
to do so i'm gonna try and go to detroit
maybe i have to do a big show before
that
to get everyone in there but then after
we'll go straight to third man records
straight to vinyl
do you have a record player yeah yeah
it's looking into that on one of my
amazon
spirals the record player they have a
lot nowadays yeah it's vinyl dude yeah
it's not going away
we're talking about people being
obsessed with things yeah vinyl is one
of them yeah get that vinyl out
that record sounds better allegedly
i remember there's there's a motorhead
album where he put in between the songs
on the cd
has like the record sound like this
i'll do that yeah sometimes
pretty sick right yeah well that's i
mean even with film that's all right
where it's like no film looks like way
better video and and photography they're
like no film all day yeah digital it's
whack
lame lame doesn't look as good doesn't
look as natural doesn't look as you know
doesn't flow with your senses
so detroit that's one city i know i'm
going to why because we wanted to flow
with our census yes sir we're going
straight to vineland street
i don't even know if that's a possible
thing
i don't i don't know if it's possible
you know people might be like you can't
do that you need you're not even a band
i'm like no i'm going to talk though
yeah it's an l you've done albums
with tracks right so this would be an
album an album straight up
you've been to jocko lives yes sir i
have some of them many big cool records
right yes sir they would be
vinyl vinyl all day man then you get
clear vinyl you get the red vinyl right
you know what i'm saying i don't know
what red vinyl is but the vinyl's red
that's what red vinyl is where you get
the clear vinyl what's clear vinyl clear
the record's clear you can see through
it
have you ever heard of that i never
heard of that before k dogs in the house
in the game yeah
so
when
i do that thing i guess it's going to be
spring or something like that we'll go
live
we'll hang out
if you're rolling up you've got that
second edition let's face it
i'm still
appreciative
sure but you know i know we all know
where you're at
uh appreciate the support let's crush
the world with this book um
echo speaking of crushing the world
we kind of have to crush ourselves
yes right in order to cross the world
which by the way make you tougher
yeah which by the way i can't just came
back from hunting
and for i think it was 13 days i did not
lift weights
because i was in the mountains brutal
or as i call mountains
but i came back and i was all fired up
you know and felt like i needed man i
have doms in my arms right now
in my i haven't had doms in my arms in a
long time dude
so
we got to crush ourselves that can take
a toll at times what do we need to do to
kind of stay on the path to get better
so we can cross the world
well keep in mind mentally and
physically dom's in the arms that
indicates that you're working out your
arms which i respect
so you know i'm sorry they have the dump
but welcome to my
world jerks
[Laughter]
well okay so we want to minimize doms
well no no maximize yet minimize
mitigate toms okay yeah i would say
that's a good call it's kind of a
dichotomy really
but let's face it
would you
would you want to have doms every day on
your arms would that include pro would
that
increase progress or not
no
it'd be bad right you know i obviously
there's a lot to it but generally
speaking simply put doms every day no
probably not okay you when the dumbs
heals then you want to elicit more dumbs
in one way or another yes but it's a
process and it's ongoing nonetheless
i'll tell you what you do need a
supplementation that'll help you through
doms or no dumps you know
so through this path we're all on
supplementation is very helpful so we'll
talk about energy drinks first right as
far as energy see i know i said it
energy drinks
as if that as if what we're talking
about fits in with all the other
categories of all these other drinks
that are in the energy drink category
yeah so may you know me if you're new to
this
[Music]
let's face it they don't don't the
stigma that you felt like in your brain
or whatever all energy drinks that
stigma don't worry about that stigma
anymore in fact forget that stigma
forget it
don't totally forget it because there's
other drinks that still have you need to
keep the stigma in mind yeah but you can
have the stigma avoidance yes like you'd
like like detach from the stigma yeah
how about that leave it behind just
leave it behind it doesn't control your
brain and how you think of energy drinks
necessarily anymore if you know about
jocko
[Music]
is it discipline go or jocko go it is
jocko discipline go technically speaking
i got corrected by someone on the inside
which i respected by the way but either
way
go
jocko discipline go it's an energy drink
that is good for you front to back good
for you not the kind where you're
drinking
um
you know what have you ever seen that
there's this commercial i think one of
these comedy youtube
channels they're like oh if so like if
energy drink commercials were honest or
whatever they called it like a
a metal tube of uh psychedelic poisoning
i don't know something but they they
kept referring to it as a metal tube of
some kind of poison yeah you know
accurate yeah well brad watch the video
it's funny you're like damn that is all
true and it's it's interesting either
way
it's not that that's not what this is no
poison it's different yeah actually good
for you it's good for you it's like a
health
drink energy drink but even though that
makes it sound kind of like not really
what it feels like
just keep in mind it's an energy drink
that tastes good
is good and it's good for you
and gives you energy and it gives you
legit no chemicals
none of these weird preservative things
because of the process of high quality
it's quality
many flavors the best in which is mango
factually in my opinion
check but you're gonna have to choose
for yourself on that one it's called
jocko go also got joint warfare yes sir
today
i i must say even joint warfare has its
limitations because i
need more right now i take it every day
uh
thank god because otherwise i might even
be completely immobilized right now
here's the thing drug warfare is not
going to help your doms oh really i mean
not me i mean maybe
the protein protein is going to help you
yes sir so joints joint warfare super
krill right
but when it comes to actual rebuild
we need to go milk yep just for the
muscle yes
additional protein in the form of the
dessert you know what i had for
breakfast this morning which i normally
don't eat milkshake
guess what i had for lunch mo because i
could
i knew what you just told me the dom's i
know it needs to be yes sir i need to
repair my muscles oh yeah freaking sore
dude
uh by the way speaking of milk the the
new and you actually all the ingredients
were in front of my face but you turned
me on to this uh or to the precursor of
this new formula for the ultimate
milkshake depends on what flavor you
like but if you like the chocolate one
this is the one mint chocolate or dark
chocolate or uh peanut butter chocolate
whichever one you want
half of a or half of a frozen banana
over ripe mm-hmm tulsi gabbard turned me
on to that okay so we got a you know a
little uh collab going on
frozen half a frozen banana two scoops
of the monk i did the darkness um soy
milk you know because like soy silk i
don't know whatever the one that it
doesn't have lactose in it so it's super
low okay if you go regular milk and
you're concerned about if you're trying
to go lower on the calorie thing
regular milk even two percent is not the
best one for you because i'm over here
on the whole milk
time straight up half and half
well you're not going on a lower calorie
scenario let's face it you can't you
know your little machine can't handle
that kind of stuff either way if you are
this is the deal because i was going to
give it to the kids for the ultimate
front-end test you see i'm saying anyway
you go half
soy milk or almond milk whatever the
unsweetened one and then half of that
it's lactose free it was the chocolate
milk that you you mentioned
it's like lactose free there's way less
sugar and it's like double triple
filtered or whatever yeah um
and you go half that too
oh just for the extra boost of chocolate
or whatever yeah
man drink that one it tastes like ice
cream i think the banana but it's not a
whole banana so you don't get the real
super banana flavor but you get the
sweetness from the banana and bro it
tastes like it's ice cream for real yeah
oh yeah put ice in there boom mix that
up there you go malt uh protein in the
form of a
highly desirable dessert highly
desirable i'm desiring one right now
i've already had two today
that's how oh it's true also jack white
t if you're into t you know something
light that's the og that's the original
that is the og oh yeah you like this is
the og i was never a tea drinker to be
honest with you and but i was and i was
surprised about how many like tea
drinkers were like brother choco white
tea is that's the legit one yeah legit
interesting
you can get all this stuff
[Music]
at vitamin shop you can get all the
stuff at jockofuel.com by the way if you
subscribe it gets shipped to you for
free
you can get the the energy
drinks here's the thing you see you
mentioned energy from time to time you
know what energy is
it's energy is an actual thing yeah it's
it's uh henry gracie's got something
yeah it's henna gracie's charisma his
whole oh that's his hair like yeah you
know when he talks he's like he's real
brother that guy's on it man you want to
listen to that guy talk forever and that
energy that he brings that's a energy
straight up
i thought it was like he may mix some
food up you know maybe an acai bowl but
that was a energy one i think the
presentation of that yeah what's the
energy so i'm just saying we got well we
need to talk to to henry and get it you
know maybe he could approve of the
energy drink over here yeah
but i think it's in the present day so
i'm just saying it might be might be i
don't know maybe maybe not but it might
be misleading to say hey they are
considered energy drinks you see i'm
saying
so i don't know so okay so this was not
officially endorsed by henry yes okay
but if you want to get these drinks
energy drinks i just made that up
because there's a jackal energy drink i
don't know
sure hell yeah if you want to get these
gent these energy drinks
you can get them at wawa as well on the
east coast and by the way we're we're
we'll be rolling out for everybody else
in the country that's not on the east
coast that's been hitting us up like
what about this store what about we're
working them and we should start to see
some of those other
big stores across the country rolling
out shortly so that's the way you can
get
some hell yeah uh yeah there you go
there you go especially uh speaking of
getting some you know you want some you
know some american-made stuff and when i
say stuff i don't mean just random stuff
right good stuff
jeans boots
various other leather goods depending on
how creative pete is feeling some
wallets in there
can you still get the wallet yep both of
them yeah there's like a small one and a
big one yeah so back to the genes delta
68 and the the what's your og factory
factory genes um
impressive genes
and i care about more elements of genes
as far as when you put on genes then
than this jocko guy
you care about a number of things which
are critical and fundamental i get it
functionality yes sir is all i care
about yes sir i understand in life but
me i care about the fit
you know when i put on the jeans fit is
part of functionality yes in my opinion
okay i care about the aesthetic
fit as well
okay see i understand yes sir
so you know when i'm in the mirror i
look in the mirror and i look at myself
and i look at my wife next to me and if
she's like giving me the approval that
means a lot
versus i put them on and she's like
stoic face maybe sour face wow that's
gotta be rough maybe let's see what else
maybe you have like those types of
reactions that means that means
my wife is just stoked
yeah yeah
well you know why she's stoked because
you put on the delta 68 like it is in my
case maybe it doesn't mean much to you
nonetheless it still reaps the same
benefits you see i'm saying and your
wife my wife
they're there to convey you know their
approval and that and around we go you
seem sane so it doesn't matter if you
notice or not
originusa.com oh yeah american-made so
when i say american-made it doesn't mean
we uh assemble them you know no in you
know disowned and grown
grown and sewn right here in america
everything from rebuilding this whole
freaking country bringing manufacturing
back to here that's what we're doing
they're doing some great stuff over
there uh also chocolate store it's
called jaco store that's where you can
get your shirts and hats and hoodies
anything you want to wear to represent
the path
discipline equals freedom
you can go deep on the the idea of
disciplinary stream by the way yes you
can yeah
sometimes kind of hard to understand but
when you understand i mean i wrote a
whole day a book about it so
i would say i win some help yes sir yes
sir nonetheless you want to represent
you ever tell me i could go deep
i have gone beat well i'm thinking you
know how okay you ever you listen to
music when you work out yes okay so
something i will too sometimes sometimes
i'll listen to podcasts depending on the
podcast sometimes the podcast can
distract you from the workout by the way
so keep that in mind but every once in a
while i'll i'll go with nothing
not listen to anything it's good that's
when your mind like you find your mind
just going deep on some random thing
that's always in front of your face or
whatever yeah and that's what happened
recently to me discipline was freedom
and man i have the freedom to do all
this stuff but i'm not gonna do it
because i'm disciplined you see i'm
saying
and you can go deep in your own mind
anyway if you're representing that you
can get your shirts and hats and hoodies
and a bunch of other stuff on
chocolatestore.com also we have a
subscription situation called the shirt
locker
kind of an exclusive deal you know it's
a monthly thing you get a new shirt
different from the from from the middle
it's slightly exclusive it's available
to anybody
it's real exclusive i'm just saying if
you're part of the short locker you're
wearing your shirt locker shirts someone
who's not part of the shirt locker
they see your shirt they're gonna be
like hey where can i get that you see
i'm saying yep that's the in exclusive
it's pseudo exclusive right nonetheless
cool cool designs
jocklestore.com speaking of
subscriptions you can subscribe to this
podcast if you want to
and uh it's everywhere we also have some
other podcast jocko unraveling podcast
with my bro daryl cooper dc we're
recording a couple this week
grounded podcast which are we even what
are we holding on to that we hold on to
it it's still out there it's yeah people
some people are waiting for it let's say
seven people it's a non-scheduled
podcast okay we'll see maybe at some
point we just roll back deep on the
grounded podcast warrior kid podcast we
also have the
underground jocko underground podcast
it's our
it's our alternative location
in case things get
tyrannical
around here
right
i don't think they will but
some days i wake up thinking maybe they
will so anyways we've built a platform
that we can operate on with pure
independence and not have to rely on the
current platforms that we're on we hope
it doesn't come to that but if it does
it would be foolish for us not to have a
contingency plan if you want to help us
with that you want to be a part of that
go to jockowunderground.com it costs 8
dollars and 18 cents a month you can
probably figure out what that stands for
eight dollars and eighteen cents a month
but listen if you can't afford that
but you still wanna support you still
wanna be in the game email assistance
jocko underground.com we'll get you in
there we release another podcast once a
week that's a little bit more
it covers some tangential topics
try and give you a little bit more
information let you know what's going on
um do a q a we're answering a bunch of
questions on there so if you want to if
you want to help us out there go to jock
underground.com yeah that one's good
it's um in the way i you know he like
you go along with a certain thing and
you could try to evaluate and maybe sum
up like what is this what what is this
right and you know you say q a which it
is essentially but it's like it's kind
of like when you go through life whether
it be currently or before whatever
i'm just saying you think about your
past you think about the present uh just
all these weird questions what what but
this is a funny way of saying it
currently or before
it is true
nonetheless you're still gonna have like
you know how there's like questions
rolling around like what is this what
does this mean like what's my take on
this at the end of the day you know if
you're the kind of ass ask that question
to yourself
i think you offer really good like your
take on it and it's usually really
informed usually
um and it can kind of help
a lot of us make sense out of certain
elements of life you know whether it be
the specific questions that people ask
or the first part that we talk about
like you know is our
are is our our children
soft now you know is society becoming
soft or like you know succumbing to the
to the trick of advertising you know
like that that kind of stuff like that's
real stuff that we're dealing with like
daily you know yeah i think it brings
awareness yeah you ever heard me talk
about if i wanted to scare you
but i told you hey i'm going to be in
the house
and i'm going to scare you what are my
chances of being able to scare you yeah
yeah lower almost zero yeah
if you don't know
yeah man and i'm going to scare you i
would say i'm 99.9
gonna scare you
yes sir so with life
if you
have an opportunity to think through a
problem
or think through a question before you
actually have to contend with it it's
gonna make you
unscarable yeah so just that's that's
another i think that's the benefit of
the jockowunderground.com
podcast is we're addressing those kind
of things to get you in that situation
where you can't be scared yeah or you're
ready to deal with whatever's in front
of you yeah yeah fully that's one of
those things
but yeah also we have a youtube channel
choco podcast youtube channel boom
excellent excerpts on there video
version of this podcast um some enhanced
stuff on there
some behind the scenes i was going to
say some behind the scenes
very occasional every once in a while
we will happen a lot of times against
your will but then it usually becomes
against my will
um and we go down like certain uh you
know little pass or whatever and here's
the thing i don't say we post behind the
scenes stuff on there even though we do
because it's not very
irregular but they're on there though
for sure if there are some
behind-the-scenes
info conversations
worth
posting
they're on there yeah
anyways i had a benefit yeah youtube
that's a good one also origin hd yeah
yeah youtube channel very good you want
to see the you want to see the
what you call like a phoenix
out of the ashes industry and how
someone can do that yep can achieve that
step by step boom that's that's a
perfect example unless you can see that
go down for sure
so yeah check that one out on youtube as
well also got a
speaking of albums now this one is not
on vinyl no
not yet anyway it's not we didn't record
it at jack white's studio in detroit
nope
i'm looking forward to that
i hope i get to do that that'd be rad
right it would be yeah especially that
kind of like where you said there's like
50 people or something like that like a
small
yeah
super hype
i wonder if i'd get super hyped for that
i think i would you know sometimes i get
hyped yes i do know
uh
well this one's not on vinyl but it's
called psychological warfare little
little
mental spots to help you get through
those moments of weakness you can get
that anywhere you get mp3s also
flipsidecanvas.com that's dakota meyer
he's got a company where they're
printing stuff for you to hang on your
wall awesome stuff keep you on the path
also got some books obviously
first and foremost
final spin
you got the intro
find out what the hype is about
it's good man
uh
pre-order it right now
comes out november
first week in november
competitive people are gonna be watching
who who's looking at it i don't know
we'll see what happens it's a risk
it's a risk i asked my editor
when disciplinary's freedom field manual
comes out came out when it was about to
come out i said have you ever taken this
much of a risk before in the book he
said no never because it's so different
he said this one
same ballpark
these kind of books this the book
doesn't exist there's no book like this
uh so final spin if you want a porch you
want to be high-fiving you want that
first to dish order that thing
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual the code the evaluation the
protocols displaced freedom field manual
the brand new version
way the warrior kit one two three and
four mikey and the dragons about faced
by hackworth and of course extreme
ownership in the regatta of leadership
that i wrote with my brother leif bap
and speaking of leif babin we have a
leadership consultancy
we solve
problems through leadership go to
echelonfront.com for details
we also have a muster coming up it's a
live event it's in las vegas october
28th and 29th
come and get some of that
you can find all those things at
ashlandfront.com we also have an online
training at extreme ownership academy
the leadership is not something you just
learn and now you're good at oh i got a
i got a shot of leadership i read one
book now i'm good no you gotta work at
it like the gym so we got a leadership
gym for you go to extreme ownership dot
com for that
and if you wanna help service members
active and retired you wanna help their
families you wanna help gold star
families check out mark lee's mom mama
lee she's got a charity organization and
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved you want to help out
go to
americasmightywarriors.org and if you
want more of my ridiculously rambling
reads or you need more of echoes obtuse
opinions
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter on the gram
and on that facebook keyboard
exactly charles i am at jacqueline and
thanks to all the men and women in the
army navy air force and marines
look final spin is a book it's a fiction
story
i sat around and came up with this idea
and wrote it and the only reason i was
able to write it the only reason i had
the freedom to write that is because you
all are out there providing security and
stability through your service so thanks
to all the military and the same goes to
our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service and all first responders
we get to do what we do because
you do what you do every day to keep us
safe
and everyone else out there
happiness
happiness isn't a destination you don't
get there you don't arrive
you are there
this is it and it might
not always seem like it
but the struggles and the sacrifice
those are life and those ultimately our
happiness
and you will find them most clearly
if you put others before yourself
so keep pushing
keep looking up
stay clean
and of course keep getting after it
and until next time
this is echo
and jocko
out